[موسيقى
] لقد جئت لزيارة جناح فيتنام
في قلب موقع المعرض
وسط أصوات الموسيقى التقليدية
والأعمال الفنية المحلية لم أكن أتوقع
أن أجد أحدث التقنيات ولكن هنا
يجلس مكان الصدارة
أكثر قطع الابتكار إثارة للاهتمام
تركز جميعها على الاستدامة من
قمر صناعي محلي الصنع
إلى هذه الدراجة المصنوعة من الخيزران
إلى هذا الحذاء
جيسي تران وسون تشو يختبران
أحدث منتجاتهما ،
التقى هذان رائدا الأعمال الفيتناميان
في فنلندا في عام 2018 وتوصلوا
إلى فكرة جذرية لإنتاج  أحذية رياضية
[موسيقى]
من القهوة بسيطة
جدًا ، لذا فإن هذا الجيل الأول نديره الآن ،
لقد جئنا من فيتنام ، وهي واحدة
من أكبر منتجي القهوة في
العالم ، ونحن نعيش هنا في
فنلندا حيث نشرب أكبر قدر من القهوة
لكل فرد في  العالم
الذي تبادلوا فيه وظائفهم في التجارة الإلكترونية
لإطلاق شركة ناشئة تتبع مفهوم الاقتصاد الدائري
حيث يتم إعادة تدوير كل منتج لصنع
منتج جديد يقلل من النفايات وانبعاثات الكربون.
ضع في اعتبارك الاستدامة
ميزة معينة مما يعني أن كل
منتج ننتجه صنعناه بالفعل من
مواد قائمة على النفايات صنع الحذاء
بالفعل من نفايات القهوة
والبلاستيك المعاد تدويره
، تتمتع المصانع في فيتنام
بإمكانية الوصول المباشر إلى أطنان من نفايات القهوة
كل عام  خمسة في المائة فقط من نظري أعتقد
أنهم يشبهون مليوني رطل من نفايات القهوة حول العالم في كل دورة و 95 في المائة يتم إلقاؤها في مكبات النفايات ، حيث يخلطون نفايات القهوة بالبلاستيك
لإنشاء خيوط
، ثم نستخدم الغزل لربط
الجزء العلوي من الأحذية
إنه مصنوع أيضًا مقاومًا للماء باستخدام تقنية النانو
[الموسيقى]
عمليًا كما لو كان هناك مثل نانو
مقاوم للماء كما لو كنت مصنوعًا من
الهواء البلاستيكي المعاد تدويره يمكن أن
يدخل ويخرج بالفعل ولكن الماء لا يمكن أن يدخل ويخرج
اليوم إيجارات الشركات الكبرى تبيع لعشرات
الآلاف من العملاء  حول
العالم ولديهم طموحات لتحدي
عمالقة مثل [ __ ] أديداس وبوما